before we jump into the uh into why i
get to talk to you guys um as a fan of
smallville i need to jump backwards to
um
bring your history uh to the forefront
if you will um i just have to ask what
do you guys remember like what what are
some of the strong memories you have of
getting your start on that series
god i remember we had we had this
amazing writer's room it was really big
and it has windows and it looked out
over burbank it was at warner brothers
looked out over burbank and the
mountains and i just remember sitting in
that room
over and over and again going oh my god
i'm really here like i'm i we're really
here
and also just the creative minds on that
show just the the writers
um and al miles who created the show
it's just just an incredibly gifted
group of people um it was not enough
there's a top two no no brian what jumps
out at you i remember going to interview
and sitting down in a chair under one of
the original corn stalks from the pilot
for some reason that fetched in my brain
um when we were interviewing for the job
um and then yeah
i i'm just curious how often did you
guys debate having a character in the
hospital say because every episode had
someone in the hospital say i gotta get
out of this town i can't be in the
hospital again
we we tried to have a little bit of a
reset or just a little slight amnesia at
the top of uh the episodes but as as if
you were a fan and watched all the way
through the series toward the end
we actually
kind of got a little more
tongue-in-cheek about about
saying things like that out loud um and
luckily uh some of our characters were
great at being able to throw off some
amazing
sarcastic sarcasm and and get away with
it
yeah i
my last thing is about the show is that
i think a lot of people don't realize
that when the show started i actually
think smallville doesn't get enough
credit for
the popularity of helping to
uh to elevate the popularity of the
superhero comic book genre because when
it started you know there was no mcu it
was just after spider-man um or just
before spider-man and after x-men it was
you know it was showing people that
there was an audience for this type of
content and i don't think the cw all the
shows that have happened exist without
something like that
and i mean and that is really
i think uh one of the things that it did
was it made um
superheroes accessible you know on on a
on a weekly basis you felt like they
could be
you know somebody living next door to
you and and with the same kinds of
problems and then trying to see how they
did it i think i don't know i the the
fan mail
and how it touched people is probably
one of the things that will stay with me
more than anything else in our career it
was really it was really moving it
really
meant a lot to a lot of people and
obviously meant a ton to us
jumping into hot zone um uh you
mentioned fan mail after making this
series are you now a lot more
aware when you're opening your mail
i'm not not until this moment now when i
have to go down to the mailbox i'm going
to be thinking about that question
thanks so much um
uh
you know i don't know i i think there's
it just was such a senseless act um
and stupid and so i i
try to just put it in a different world
and
and hopefully we are never
things like you know
um deadly bacteria being mailed out to
people um
i don't know it's an unnerving topic
definitely 100 how did you guys decide
on anthrax being this season's hot zone
was it the studio was it you guys how
did that idea come about
it was a collaboration but we we had put
together a pretty big list and i know
kelly especially was a huge proponent of
this idea mainly because of the
character because just like in the first
season
you know
more than an episode about a show about
ebola he was very much about this woman
nancy jackson and this season um you
know the bruce ivan's character was with
such a gripping
a you know a gripping journey to take
and i think it was not i think that geo
really had said to us well let's go
let's really get get into this and look
at it
um because i think at first we kind of
were like i don't really understand and
then and then reading into it we were
like oh yeah this is a really really
unique
um story on many different levels
one of the things um it's uh one of the
things i really like is that it it's
only six episodes and it is very fast
moving those first few episodes just fly
there is no wasted content wasted scenes
um how do you guys decide on the six
episodes is it like a budgetary thing is
it because that's where the scripts land
what's the what's the decision making
behind that
it's really about what kind of fits for
the for the network and i think that uh
six parts is something that you can you
can finish off in the morning um you
know it's something that's uh very um
contained um it never loses pace it just
keeps flying and it changes um certainly
episodes five and six are extremely
different compared to episodes one and
two um it really kind of almost turns
into a different show in some ways
uh so i think i think six just kind of
seems like the the happy number um for
sitting down and just binge watching or
you know watching in three consecutive
nights um
with the nat geo premiere
just to be clear i watched it over two
days it wasn't just that
i just wanted all right well that's good
just
just to be clear um it's a lot of
amtrak's for one day
yeah
i did the anyway um so this is obviously
you're basing this on what really
happened but you're also making a tv
show so can you talk about that line of
fact and fiction and where you felt like
you could take some leaps and where
you're like this has to be accurate
well the events are accurate i mean that
is not we're not going to make up you
know some breakthrough on the case or
anything that that we're making
something out geo who which is a
you know a group that we obviously
really respect um and has a lot of
respect around the world so we're not
going to
just collectively we don't want to make
something that isn't you know grounded
uh really where we take liberties is in
creating characters like all the fbi
agents um and uh instead of fleshing out
a little bit just so that you can track
the story but we're not there to um you
know
suddenly create create all kinds of
things about somebody that that we
didn't
you know pull from research we really
did an immense amount of research along
with a lot of other people the writers
staff the other assistants and um and
certainly not geo research department as
well so everything's sort of been gone
over with a fine tune and um fine comb i
mean and uh
and so what you're seeing
what's unfolding the story that unfolds
is what happened
that's that's not the part that we come
in and
you know take liberties
one of the things i think that the
series does really well is i think
people forget what it was like after 9
11 and that
ever the freak like the how can i word
this um how scared everyone was that
this could happen again and that
everyone was just freaking out over
everything and you know can you sort of
talk about especially in the first few
episodes sort of capturing that energy
and putting it on screen reminding the
viewer like what that was like back then
well one specific thing that i
you know it brings us i remember getting
on a plane i think within a couple weeks
i could be wrong but we've definitely
been a month of 9 11. and it was
unfortunate we were all very suspicious
of each other and so we wanted
to build in a moment there's a moment
and i think it's in the second episode
um that i think will will
resonate with certain audience members
that were flying at that time
oh and i think
yeah
that one i know
and i think you know i think also
you know it was something that was in
the scripts but also something that we
talked about a lot in prep meetings and
production meetings with our directors
with the you know the actors were
certainly aware of it every from like
costume hair makeup we wanted we wanted
to not present people as perfectly
glossy and completely together people
were exhausted
their their patience was run thin
they were a little cranky you know i
mean i i think there's an opening scene
that dylan baker is sort of leading a
group of fbi agents and i think you can
feel
how tense how angry you know they're
exhausted they just want to you know
bring somebody to justice they want some
kind of justice for everything that's
going on and i think you can really feel
it and it's sort of across the board
from the from the design to the acting
to the you know obviously the the script
but um
we want we wanted people to try to
remember or get get the first feeling if
they weren't there at the time
how this really was invading every
minute of our lives for for a long
period of time
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats and i look forward to the
next uh hot zone whatever that may be
from that sheet of paper that you had
created
thank you so much